le 20 novembre est désormais la journée
du souvenir trans une date fixe pour se
rappeler les personnes assassinées au
suicidé en raison de leur orientation
sexuelle ou identité de genre dimanche à
rassemblement évalué à Tours pour leur
rendre hommage et dénoncer les
agressions de plus en plus fréquentes à
l'égard de cette communauté les
explications de Faustine Nuno
ce sont 327 personnes trans assassinées
qui ont été recensés des chiffres qui
viennent du transmember monitoring qui
comptabilise les victimes de transphobie
pour cette journée mondiale du souvenir
l'organisation de solidarité trans de
Tours appelaient les tours enjaux à se
réunir en fait on se demande comment
est-ce qu'un jour ça sera moi est-ce
qu'un jour ce sera une personne que je
connais et plus généralement combien de
morts est-ce qu'il va falloir pour qu'on
pour que les gens comprennent qu'en fait
c'est pas c'est pas les personnes trans
le problème l'association crée il y a un
an accompagne et conseils les personnes
trans dans leur démarche de transition a
commencé par leur changement de prénom
et de mention de sexe au tribunal moi
personnellement je l'ai fait là c'est
tout récent on doit se présenter devant
des juges pour prouver encore une fois
qu'on est des personnes trans on doit le
prouver parce qu'en plus il nous demande
de raconter un peu notre histoire et on
doit le prouver via des témoignages donc
c'est à dire qu'on doit demander à des
personnes proches de témoigner donc à la
main en écrivant qu'elle nous
connaissent bien sous notre prénom
qu'elle nous connaissent bien sous ce
genre là maintenant et que c'est notre
réalité moi mon changement de prénom a
été refusé là je suis en train de faire
de nouvelles démarches pour faire
recours en quelque sorte c'est tous ces
petits trucs ça rend effectivement
la reconnaissance auprès des autres très
compliqué l'organisation propose
également des permanences pour les
personnes trans et pour leurs proches
elle peut les guider vers des médecins
ouverts à la transition quand on a des
organisations de médecins qui sont pas
nécessairement favorables le droit des
personnes trans qui nous considèrent
encore comme des sujets psychiatriques
c'est encore le cas oui oui c'est encore
le cas c'est encore c'est encore le cas
majoritairement où il y a assez peu de
médecins qu'on s'est favorables enfin
qui peuvent nous aider les permanences
de l'organisation de solidarité trans
ont lieu les premiers et 3e mercredi du
mois rue Georges Delperier à Tours